With certain stitch patterns
like tuck and lace, they require
even weight across your knitting.
One way to achieve this is
to use a ribber cast on comb.
Now, even if you don't have a ribber
attached, the comb can come in handy.
On a single bed, put every other needle
into work, leaving the other
needles in out of work position.
Knit across, forming loops.
Carefully push that cast on comb
into the loops that are formed.
Insert the wire in the comb.
Now, be careful to keep that comb
and the wire in front
of the gate pegs and pull down.
The knitting should look like this.
Keeping the comb out of the way
of the carriage, knit across.
Then put all the needles
into work and knit a few rows.
Hang some ribber weights as needed.
With this scrap in place,
you can now knit a row of ravel cord
and work a closed cast
on to continue your knitting.